[Music]
is
[Music]
good morning welcome back and if you're
new here i'm zaiha i'm a third year
medical student in the uk so for the
past three weeks i had way too many
assessments i had a written clinical
knowledge exam i had to present in two
different conferences and now i'm
preparing for the final exam of the
third year of medical school ever so my
final exam of the year is a practical
exam in the uk the practical exams are
called oski's so objective structured
clinical examinations and i have only
three days left until i'm officially
done with this year to three days until
my oscars and that's why now i'll be
taking you with me into campus so we can
practice some of the clinical
examinations that can come up in the
exam
[Music]
this patient isn't cardiac arrest can i
get some help please i'm in the
hospitalized okay double to double to
and get the questions
[Music]
[Music]
so between shoulder blades
five times
what about if it's a child if it's a
child i would get them like that and
then
how many times would you do it again oh
three rounds yeah if not then i start
feeling
[Music]
wow
[Music]
i'm back home from clinical skills now
this morning i was just really
refreshing my mind on stuff that i've
done before anyway so i just wanted to
touch the equipment and play with it one
last time if you've seen my previous
vlog about the conference week you would
have known that i've been going into
practice oscars whenever i have time
because as you practice more you get
more confident in it and the examiner
can see that confidence as well so in
oski's there are different types of
skills that they can ask you about there
are examinations communication skills
and procedures so what i practiced this
morning were procedures such as ecg
taking and youtube insertion or airway
management now i'll practice some
examinations and communication skills
with my flatmates so communication
skills are like breaking bad news to a
patient whose test results showed cancer
so talking to them and informing them
appropriately about their diagnosis or
taking histories from patients so asking
them about their past medical history
drug history family history etc etc
they're all communication skills then
we'll move on to examinations such as
cardio exam or hip and shoulder
examinations now let's get on with that
great thank you you lift them to your
sides you can end this eyes they can go
let's never
cross them in front of your body
now if you just bend your arms like this
[Music]
you know what acj is clavicular joint
abduction
external rotation
extension
internal
light
[Music]
hello i'm vega i'm a third year medical
student studying at the university of
ecuador today i've been asked to talk to
you about what's brought you in here
would that be all right that's okay
could i just confirm your name and say
so please perfect so james could you
tell me what's bringing you in here
today so for the past couple of days
i've just noticed this sharp pain in my
chest like it comes on when i go up or
down the stairs
okay so it's worse when you're doing
activities and exercising is that right
yeah that's fine
and how would you describe this thing
it's just in the center of my chest it's
like a sharp stabbing
kind of sensation and if you have to
rate this thing from one to ten ten
being the worst pain ever one being no
pain how would you rate this thing oh
it's got a six out of ten
hi there my name is james forbes i'm a
third year medical student from the
university of exeter i'd just like to
have a chat with you about some of these
results that we've just gotten yeah
would that be okay yes that's fine
so to begin with can i get you to
confirm your name and date of birth for
me please yes it's really hot you know
okay and what would you like to be
called very high it's fine all right so
what were you expecting to go through
today so i've been told that i could
potentially have cancer i was just
worried about that and they told me to
get a scan and now i got a scan now i
want to know the results so that's why
i'm here
are you happy for me to go through those
results now yes thanks okay i'm sorry to
say it's really hard it's not good so we
did do a scan and unfortunately we found
that there is cancer kingdom of liberty
okay we're done practicing now not gonna
lie i've been kind of feeling stressed
about this osu i think it's the fact
that this is the last exam of the year
and i just don't want to ruin my third
year last minute it's the pressure of
wanting to end this year on a good note
which kind of makes me feel anxious but
i know i'm going to be okay and i just
can't wait for this to be all over so i
can start my summer and get my life back
basically now i'm going to hang out with
some friends we're going to go into town
get some ice cream then watch love
island just to de-stress and relax from
a long day of studying so that i can
keep myself calm and relaxed before the
exam which is very important i hope this
gave you a good insight of how i study
for my practical exam as a medical
student if you'd like to see more
content from me please consider
subscribing and liking this video now
let's try and relax before the exam
[Music]
okay
i don't want you to to worry too much
although this is extremely difficult
[Music]